galandrial is among the most powerful
and mysterious characters in the lord of
the rings
and her long history stretches back to
the earliest days of middle-earth itself
from her blessed beginning serve final
journey here is galadriel's entire
backstory explained
galadriel's life began back in the
earliest recorded days of elven history
when the elves first awake in
middle-earth they're initially led by
the god-like beings known as the valar
who lived far across the sea in a
westernly realm known as
valiner the elves first come to valiner
to help protect them from the dark lord
morgoth
a fallen vala who's hell bent on wiping
out both the elves and
pretty much the rest of creation too in
fact one of the origin stories for the
orcs suggests that morgoth caught some
of these young elves before they
migrated west
torturing them half to death and slowly
turning them into the first generation
of works
do you know how the orcs first came into
being
they were elves once over time many of
the elves that aren't captured or killed
make their way across middle earth
until they arrive at their new home and
it's here roughly three thousand years
later
that galadriel is born for the record
that makes the lady of lorien over 8 000
years old when the events of the lord of
the rings takes place
in her youth galadriel maintains a
stellar reputation in the heavenly
kingdom
she's born into royalty and is both an
impressive lore loremaster
and a gifted athlete according to
tolkien's unfinished tales
she's said to be the tallest of all the
women of the eldar
and is recorded to be around six foot
four inches in height
while her beauty is brought up on
multiple occasions however it's her hair
that is most frequently mentioned
in the silmarillion it stated that her
hair was lit with gold
as though it had caught in a mesh the
radiance of loralyn
loreland as it happens was one of the
two magic trees that lit valiner
before the sun and moon were created in
his book unfinished tales
tolkien even suggests that galadriel's
hair is like the light of both trees
mixed together
and that it inspires the great elven
craftsman feyenoor
to create the silmarils the titular
jewels of the silmarillion
the silmarils eventually attract the
attention of morgoth
who had previously destroyed the two
trees and sets himself
on stealing the jewels sparking a
devastating war with the elves in the
process
galadriel's royal pedigree makes it
difficult for the elven princess to
avoid the limelight
and eventually her lofty position drags
her into one of the most
infamous events in middle earth's early
history when morgoth
destroys the two trees and steals the
silence it sparks a rebellion in veliner
feeling betrayed by the valar guardians
a large faction of elves decide to
reject their protection in velanor
opting to take things into their own
hands instead by chasing the enemy back
to middle earth
where he's fled with their priceless
gems one group of these elves seizes a
fleet of ships by killing their elven
guard
and sail back across the sea to the
western shores of middle-earth
the larger host with galadriel in their
midst doesn't participate in this battle
but they're nonetheless unsettled by the
coming of morgot and feel a powerful
calling to return to the lands that they
came from
so they too decide to leave valiner with
no ships left behind
by feyenoord's elves however they're
forced to travel northwards across a
stretch of land known as the hell caraxe
the hell caraca is where baliner and
middle earth come closest together
in the silmarillion tolkien describes
the hal karaxia as a place filled with
vast fogs and mists of deathly cold and
the sea streams are filled with clashing
hills of ice
and the grinding of ice deep sunken
needless to say many elves perish in the
crossing
but the survivors do eventually reach
the shores of middle earth
once galadriel arrives back in middle
earth she spends the next several
hundred years lying low
by this point the first stage of middle
earth has begun
and the land is ravaged by war as the
elves and their allies
are slowly ground down by morgoth and
his armies eventually after 500 years of
conflict
the valar themselves arrived to take on
morgoth
and cast the dark lord into the void of
space
notably during this time gladreal visits
the elephant kingdom of doriath
and it's here that she meets an elven
prince named keleborn
the two fall in love and eventually
marry soon galadriel and kelliborn pack
up
and head further eastwards leaving all
the politics behind in search of a
peaceful existence
deeper within the continent when the
first age ends with the defeat of
morgoth
many of the exiled elves returned to
baliner some of them however
head further east where they find
galadriel and kelleborn
already settled down at this point
middle earth has entered the second age
still over six thousand years from the
lord of the rings in the hobbit
which take place at the end of the third
age with the world changed immeasurably
since the dark days of morgoth
galatrial and caliburn begin to dabble
with the idea of taking on legitimate
political leadership
just what happened next is kind of up in
the air however
partly because tolkien mentions
contradictory details in each version of
the story that he wrote
what is known is that during this time
galadriel and kelleborne
lead two separate elven communities in
northwestern middle earth
roughly 750 years into the second age
they move on and heads southeast into
aragian
an area ruled by a distant cousin of
collaterals named
kelebrimbor this is the same region
where the fellowship of the ring
is later tracked by birds and finds the
doors of moria
from there galadriel eventually makes a
trip with her daughter
calebrian through the dwarven mines and
pays her first visit to the elms that
live in lothlorien
kelleborn who isn't all that fond of
dwarves remains behind for the time
being by this point a new foe has set
himself up in middle earth
morgoth's chief necromancer and second
in command
sauron you probably know what happens
next
in disguise sauron visits the elven
kingdoms of middle-earth
charming them with his knowledge and
teaching them how to forge rings of
power
and in the darkness
after keller brimbour forges the three
elven rings one
is given to gladreal but when sauron
creates his master ring
he's unable to use it to control the
elves because he didn't physically have
a hand in their creation
realizing what has happened the elves
take off their rings
and decide to keep them hidden from the
new dark lord
when sauron forges the one ring and
reveals his true identity to middle
earth
it begins the war of the elves and
sauron which ends roughly 300 years
after galadriel first arrived in
lothlorien
after the war wraps up she leaves lorien
and
heads back east to find kelleborn
eventually the two meet again
in rivendell and decide to wander
middle-earth
during this period they spend a good
amount of time in rivendell itself
as well as the area that eventually
becomes western gondor
a lot happens in middle earth over the
next few thousand years to say the least
but it doesn't seem like galadriel or
caliborn have much impact on these
events
in fact it's not until the third age
that everything changes for the couple
in the 1981st year of this era
long after sauron's defeat at the hands
of the lost alliance
the king of lothlorien dies caliborn and
galadriel
then return to the woodland kingdom
where they officially become the lord
and lady
of the golotham tolkien goes to great
pains on multiple occasions to point out
that
kelliborn and galadriel aren't the
straight-up rulers of lorien
but there's no doubt that at this point
they're the top dogs in the golden wood
after she takes up leadership of
lothlorien with her husband galadriel
spends the next few centuries using her
knowledge
and her ring to help the land blossom
preparing it for the inevitable conflict
she knows is coming
then 2463 years into the third age
galadriel calls the white council for
the first time
this was a group of wise leaders in
middle earth that included among others
saruman elrond and gandalf initially
glad trail attempts to make gandalf the
head of this council of the wise
but the wizard turns down the honor and
saruman ends up getting the nod instead
by now the white wizard is already
starting to turn away from the light
and he intentionally steers the council
in the wrong direction
on more than one occasion nevertheless
over the next five centuries
the white council gets to work they
identify the necromancer in murkwood as
sauron keep tabs on his ever-growing
power and eventually take action and
drive him out of his fortress of dol
guldur
beware the necromancer he is not what he
seems
[Music]
throughout all this drama galadriel
remains intimately connected to the
activities of the council
frequently participating in its sessions
and standing shoulder to shoulder with
wizards and warriors alike
as they rally together to take on the
greatest threat to middle-earth since
the fall of morgoth
for tolkien movie fans this will all
begin to seem like more familiar
territory
having being revealed to the world by
the white council sauron retreats to
mordor
galadriel meanwhile prepares lorien for
war
she plays her first critical role in the
war of the ring when she is visited by
the fellowship of the ring after they
escape from the mines of moria
after she harbors the fellowship
galadriel gives them a number of
important gifts and sends them on their
way she also welcomes a newly
resurrected gandalf
who's recovering from his epic
mountaintop battle with the balrog
galadriel plays a crucial role in
helping gandalf to remember who he was
bringing him up to speed and equipping
him with the knowledge he needs for the
rest of the war
even after these two important events
galadriel's role in the war continues
in the books she sends a cryptic message
to aragorn warning him that he must take
the paths of the dead to help defeat
sauron's forces in gondor
in addition lothlorien is attacked by
orcs three times during the war but
galadriel
her ring and her elven armies repel all
three attacks
after this galadriel and kelliborn lead
their warriors into merkwood
where they capture dol guldor and the
lady of the wood uses her ring to
utterly destroy its walls
and cleanse the forest for good at the
end of the war of the ring
galadriel finally grows weary of the
mortal lands of middle earth
she attends arwen's wedding to aragorn
and then a couple of years later
decides to finally take a ship back to
valiner
joining elrond gandalf frodo and bilbo
galadriel boards a ship and sails into
the west
kelleborn however is unwilling to leave
quite yet and temporarily relocates to
rivendell where elrond's two sons still
live
it's even said that mario doc brandy
buck traveled to the fading elvish
stronghold to speak with kelleborne
and ask for his help in compiling the
history of the wars of middle earth
eventually though the longing for both
the west and his wife went out
and caliborne joins galadriel in their
new home across the sea
while recorded life ends on this
bittersweet note
there's one more part of her story
that's worth mentioning gimli the dwarf
is famous for his admiration of
galadriel
to the point he even asks for a strand
of her hair to remember her by
i asked her for one hair from her golden
head
[Music]
she gave me three interestingly
tolkien also says that galadriel manages
to get permission from the valar
for gimli to join her in retirement in
valiner itself
making him the only dwarf to ever set
foot on the shores of the undying lands
this benevolent act is a fitting final
footnote for the illustrious story
of the most famous woman in middle
earth's entire history
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you